Messieurs , dames merci de faire un tonnerre d'applaudissement pour les grands
Les beaux
Yann et Mickalow!
(Applaudissements...)
Stop
Aujourd'hui on est sur What The Box et finalement
comme le Prop-Hunt en en gros on est tous des boîtes.
Parmi d'autres boîtes qui ne sont pas des joueurs
et il faut trouver quelles boîtes sont des joueurs pour les éliminer.
C'était la meilleur explication de toute ma chaîne Youtube.
Vous êtes prêt ? Je vous laisse 7 secondes.
Top!......1
2...3...4...5...6...7... (micka) Ah c'est facile!
Alors on est là.
(Rire)
On dirait un petit délinquant avec son cutter. (Micka)
Wow ha ha
Ah je m'y attendais pas...
Viens là fils de p*te  vous êtes en état d'arrestation !
Non ! Non ! Non !!! Ok c'est bon
Suivant. (Yann) Alors eh, tu sais quoi ? Vu que je sais pas où est Mika.
Je viens t'aider. (Squeezie) Ok vas-y viens m'aider
Tu penses qu'il s'est mit où ? Là?
(Yann) Je me demande justement s'il ne serait pas resté en plein milieu vu qu'on est partis
du millieu. (Ricanement Diabolique (Micka) )
tirons ! tirons ! tirons ! bombardons!
Mais c'est pas possible. Mais il est où ?
(Micka) eh il est simple ce jeu (rire)
Mais il est où le bâtard ? Mec j'ai tiré dans toutes les caisses mon gars.
C'est trop marrant, je vous vois comme des gros tirer (rires)
Attend ! Il est là ! Il est là !
ah non c'est toi pardon (rires) c'est toi c'est toi
(éclatent de rire)
(en riant) on est trop sous pression
De toute façon, il peut pas... Il peut pas y avoir de boîte...
Oh je l'ai trouvé, oh le batard comment il était caché
Putain le petit enculé comment il était cacher
Oh le batard, il était là, mon gars. Il était ici l'enculé
Bon bas, Micka, clairement tu es gagnant de ce round
Ok, on refait sauf que cette fois, on va à la plateforme bleu au dessus
Et le chat, c'est le premier que j'ai trouvé donc c'est Yann
Allez, 1
4 [Rire de squeezie]
Yann : 10 J'ARRIVE [Toujours rire de squeezie]
*Squeezie crie d'une façon très virile*
Bravo, nan mais là c'était extrêmement rapide
y'a qu'une seule tour avec 5 boites. (Squeezie) Attends Micka vous savez
quoi ?
On fait un truc celui qui cherche qui se met en première personne en vue première personne
Micka : Au première personne
Squeezie : Allez vas-y tu comptes jusqu'a 10 et tu fermes tes yeux
2...3...4
Yann : hih je sais je sais
5..6..7
JE PEUX PAS
9..10
Squeezie : c'est pas grave abandonne abandonne
Yann : Mais non j'ai abandonné j'ai abandonné
*Rire de Yann et Squeezie*
AHH *Rire en applaudissant
Ah non c'est une bonne idée . Micka : t'sait qu'en vrai je te voyais pas mais je me suis douter que t'avais fait une connerie comme ça
allez c'est parti a vos cachette
Où ils peuvent être ces cons
Bah qu'est-ce que c'est que cette pile énorme
Ah les bâtards
J'suis sur que vous êtes pas la
J'suis sur que vous êtes par la les gars
Oh Yanou Oh Yanou
Allez hop ça dégage suivant
Oh la la Micka
Ou est-ce qu'il peut être Mickalow
Mais c'est moi ça mais c'est moi
Yann pourquoi t'as balances Micka c'est énervé
Il est ou ce con
Nan ! sérieux t'a pas réussi à le buté.
Nan je sais pas ou il est il a disparus
attend pour le match amical face à leur
portée le magasin parce que penser des
chiots qui écoutait t placer ses pions
droits réservés voilà voilà voilà
un peu plus près
l'immeuble filtrés dans la merde à
l'appui de sa requête le musée maillol
dans la baston et lens ne pouvaient pas
lutter à kinshasa shyamalan
diane 7 automne
kurth cobain des salaires
non vraiment pourquoi
hors exceptionnels
1 04% acteurs ou les squelettes c'est ce
que je veux
accoyer silhouette quatre athlètes
être plus précis
mais c'est pas possible j'ai pu tout
cela
barack obama
mais comme il l'avait déjà fait quatre
morts braaten
il fait peut-être pas tort
l'arrêté trotta robert pattinson pas
pu pas de toute façon
j j'ai transpiré des pages d'or je
deviens plus bas alors quoi
mais pour en arriver là mais il faut
ajouter qu'elle ait pas de retard au
général de l'ump à l'arrière le
casse-tête 27e
ce qui a valu pas mal de la floride
pourraient sur de partenariat
vers 1h20 lacazette à mieux cette
nouvelle règle celui qui meurent il
revient celui qui va chercher les deux
hôtes
10 l'agent de voyages
quand ils me voient leur poste mariano
cohn quant au tour de patrick et 6 ans
on s'embrasse la salle faire un nom et
siroter un petit café ou moins appareil
c'est quoi le prends pas mal hein j'ai
pas de moto
entrée libre
elle adopte d'ici peu je ne suis
toujours pas pourquoi on est là
j'arrive à rester à clermont qui a
fait tomber l armée issue cache pas que
ça parce qu'il ya des glaciers bref il
s'est séparé
je suis satisfait ça me rappelle un peu
le bordel
le parquet a fait une carrière c'est
rassurant de savoir qu'il est possible
de réserver le droit d'engager une
politique à côté de cet écart vous
au mois d'août
pour moi je pense que j'ai fait un petit
cadeau la coopérative à mon pote
à la reprise lecture du verdict est
tombé
alerte à la bombe a fait au patin ap
droits réservés préparer et là
non non maintenant qu'elle passe mariana
otero
pour les chinois
eric woerth at-elle vers le bas a été
atteint william ward
dunne par
pour sa part rachat côté comme cela
archos lâche-t-elle
il est aujourd'hui n'est plus
il faudra la chaleur la main à la pâte
à la hâte et à pékin
d'une part elle a frappé le japon la
carte graphique même s'il advenait
qu'il y ait des caisses desjardins ap
de gaulle
alitalia n'entame que ça
vous verrez
merci à tous
claire coates a déclaré price
ça repart hamel même que ça s'arrête
là car l'argent à l'arrière-garde
adverse
vous êtes un cas de conscience pour moi
d'être catho de la mer noire l'accident
j'ai reproduit ce samedi exactement dans
quelles eaux
pour les fêtes
la papda kg de cannabis 8 à laval je
plussoie je ne trouvais pas d'autographe
avec frédéric heures p 8 milliards
d'euros ces êtres pays m 10
mais dans la réserve navale le texte ne
comporte pas être acceptées et les
coéquipiers au club qui peut plus
mature
alors oui la victoire est impérative
ouattara artois j'observe qu'il affecte
à la fois sur l entrée devant moi du
territoire
il faut encore la boule du goût du jour
d'autant qu'une fois lors du contrôle
d'un juge qui va bien au-delà des 33
tirs dans le sud
à bon entendeur hervé me
il faudra un travail arabe
6 heures 7
les petits après neuf la police
voitures les plus célèbres de bataille
reuters quelle personne qui a écrit
qu'il le fait avec busquets c'est un
résultat décevant
outsourcia
l'allusion et pourquoi bettman elle est
capable mais déjà les mesures prises
aux balles
sans toutefois battre en effet d'aller
les voir de près le joueur le plus
utile possible apple
qu'en est-il
c'est une personne si ce ne fut pas en
reste abbas
alors
mais actuellement je t'embrasse la paire
de manches
dans la série rama yade l'agenda 21 des
gains sur waterloo gratter des ballons
d'essai vous à budapest et caroline
fiset pas à la mesure des dégâts
quand même pas et puis c'est surtout
qu'on a trouvé les bonnes règles oui
des jeux dont la diffusion n'est pas
ensemble et s'arme jeu qu'importe bref
c'est vrai c'est vrai de montrouge a la
preuve aujourd'hui fusionnée que pour
un mois à moi j'applaudis pour cette
vidéo
Yann: urine
voila j'attendais sa F.D.P